hey 42 here you may be surprised but
McDonald's it's no longer the world's
biggest restaurant chain subway is with
7,000 more locations worldwide than
McDonald's McDonald's have 31,000
restaurants internationally McDonald's
has more customers daily than the entire
population of Great Britain they serve
over 68 million people every day that's
about one percent of the world's
population McDonald's serves 75
hamburgers every second and was one of
the few businesses that grew throughout
the recession McDonald's 27 point five
billion year Li revenue makes it the
90th largest economy in the world
McDonald's has seven hundred and sixty
one thousand employees worldwide more
than the entire population of Luxembourg
it is estimated that one in every eight
American workers has been employed by
McDonald's in fact too many celebrities
worked at McDonald's before they became
famous including Rachel Adams Sharon
Stone Shania Twain Jay Leno pink and
James Franco McDonald's is the world's
largest distributor of toys with one
included in 20 percent of all sales
between 2011 and 2013 McDonald's plans
to open one restaurant everyday in China
in the continental US you are never more
than 107 miles away from a McDonald's
the father spot away from a McDonald's
in the u.s. lies in the grasslands of
South Dakota between two tiny Hamlet's
called meadow and glad Valley at this
spot you are 107 miles or at least a
two-hour car journey away from a
McDonald's Americans alone consume an
artery busting 1 billion pounds of beef
at McDonald's every year
that's 5.5 million cattle the ominous
McDonald's golden arches are recognized
by more people internationally than the
cross a survey found that 88% of people
could identify the arches but only 54%
the Christian crops there are 10
countries where you won't find a single
McDonald's these are North Korea the
Seychelles Syria the Vatican City
Cambodia Zimbabwe Vietnam Nepal
Kazakhstan which is the largest country
in the world to be McDonald's free and
finally Barbados McDonald's sells unique
items in every country did you know that
in Portugal you can order soup at
McDonald's and in India where the
majority of the population doesn't eat
beef McDonald's serve meals such as the
chicken Maharaja Mac and the potato
patty McHale ooh tikki burger in Hong
Kong you can order a red bean pie for
dessert in France they sell a burger on
a stone oven-baked see a butter roll
pulp fiction fans will be happy to hear
that yes you can buy a beer in
McDonald's in France the Netherlands
Germany and Austria and all across
Europe you can order a Royale with
cheese
McDonald's is a single largest owner of
real estate in the world they actually
make the majority of their revenue from
the rent paid to them from their
franchise owners McDonald's paid rappers
to mention Big Macs in their songs to
appeal more to young people hip hop
artists were paid about $5 every time
one of their songs with Big Mac and no
lyrics
played in the US but where in the world
will you pay the most for a Big Mac
Norway in Norway you'll pay the
equivalent of 23 US dollars for a single
McDonald's meal of a big mac soda and
fries in Hong Kong mcdonald's has
wedding packages on its menu yes you can
actually get married at McDonald's
hamburgers and chicken nuggets aren't
that profitable one of the most
profitable items on McDonald's menu is
soft drinks McDonald's is the world's
largest retailer of Coca Cola but the
coke sold at McDonald's isn't your
traditional soda most fast-food chains
by Coca Cola syrup for about 55 pence
per liter then they add the syrup to
carbonated water a medium coke that
sells for 75 pounds only contains 5
pence worth of syrup buying a large coke
for 85 pens cost the retailer another 2
pence worth of silver and last but not
least McDonald's apple pies are the
hottest substance No
to month thanks for watching until next
time